journalists comedians and actors figured
prominently in
india's metoo movement in 2018
coming out with stories of harassment at
the hands of men in power
a recent court verdict acquitting an
accuser in a defamation case was seen as
a victory for women who have spoken out
against harassment
while offices and workplaces are
gradually improving protections offered
to workers
many women in the informal sector remain
invisible within the movement
in india dw follows such a worker who
wants to emphasize that time is indeed
up bharatirani is well known in her
neighborhood
she stops and talks to other domestic
workers who live nearby
many are now friends but some close
their doors
she's too much of an activist they say
she doesn't mind though
she wants to make sure that other young
women and girls are never afraid
like she was once to speak out
against harassment the employers treat
us with such disgust
we can't sit next to them we can't sit
on the couch we can't eat at the table
we can't eat from the plates we only
have a right to wash them so how dare he
touch me
if i can't sit next to you how dare you
put your hand on me
bharti was only eight years old when she
was sent to work for a rich family
and to live with them without pay it's a
common arrangement
in indian cities which activists say
amounts to modern slavery
harassment and abuse by employers is
common too
and domestic workers often say they
can't afford to speak out at the risk of
losing their jobs
but bharti stresses that it is better to
lose a job with dignity
than to suffer through one without
nansabhat heads of women's rights ngo
she points out that while me two
testimonials occupied mostly digital
spaces
she found similar reactions amongst
bharti and other domestic workers
offline as well they asked women to
share
their workplace harassment experiences
through art and writing
and stitched it together on a saree
calling it maybe
which means me too in hindi so when they
displayed the piece
recalls there was a stunned silence they
didn't realize that
you know there are others like them as
well they thought that they were the
only ones
who had experienced sexual harassment at
the world of works it got them to talk
about it
realize that what has happened to them
is um
unfair and they can't speak and they're
not alone
this isn't just about her she wants to
ensure that her daughter grows up
watching her mother live with dignity
knowing that she deserves it too
whatever i say whatever i tolerate my
baby is absorbing it
it saddens me i don't want her to learn
this
she's better than me she'll be stronger
than me
this is why i tell women to rise to
raise their voice
if not for themselves then for their
children to make them strong
bharti says that she wants her daughter
to be unafraid of the rich
to have a big house herself a
comfortable job
she's confident her daughter can be just
like them
but a much much kinder person